arkady bob Schenker a russian journalist
known for his fierce criticism of
president putin lying in what looked
like a pool of his own blood at his home
in kiev except it wasn't his own no
quibble Anastasia it was pig's blood on
me they poured blood all over me I put
some in my mouth and let it out they put
some blood into the bullet holes and I
was dead but Gingka stunned the world
when he reappeared as if from the dead
at a news conference on Wednesday it had
all been an elaborate ruse he told
journalists set up by the Ukrainian
Secret Service to catch his would-be
killer and their supposedly FSB handlers
today Bob Schenker defended the role he
played a lot of journalists say you
crossed a line here haven't you just
made it harder for people to trust what
journalists say just occasionally those
journalists who believe that I crossed a
red line when they come to you show you
your photograph and a photograph of your
hit man and ask you dude do you want to
survive or do you want to preserve
ethics and morals of your profession I
chose the option to survive mr. Cyr
Stanko was part of an investigative team
trying to find out what had happened if
we had some more time you know I think
that we if I were I found out that it's
not true
how much longer do you think you would
have needed maybe a couple of forests
editor thinks Ukraine has done itself a
disservice I think that there's a huge
credibility issue that is gonna hit
Ukraine not well perhaps now as well but
more and they in the mid to long long
term it's a big issue I mean Ukrainians
Secret Service and law enforcers are do
have a problem with credibility already
and having fooled the whole world and
having fooled you know foreign
governments international institutions
not to mention our own people is a big
deal
Kiev hasn't exactly provided safe refuge
to Russian dissidents to date two years
ago Belarusian journalist pavel shalom
yet was killed in a car bomb and the
russian former MP denis foreign yankov
who'd fled to kiev and was gunned down
in broad daylight on this street in
March last year if our car debuff genka
had escaped an assassination plot as the
ukrainian security services say you've
got to wonder how much safer he is now
of chenko told journalists all he wanted
was to go back to a normal life if you
want things to settle down why write
something like you want to dance on
Putin's grave keep his mother how can
you translate this into Russian without
swearing because I hate him I hate this
person this person is responsible for
Wars and thousands of deaths I had to
bury the people I knew I had to bury my
colleagues my friends
I'm tired of burying people brave words
deeply held beliefs from years on the
front lines of Russia's Wars as a
soldier and war correspondent
Diana Magnay Sky News Kiev